en este vídeo veremos cómo escribir las
configuraciones electrónicas usando la
notación de los gases nobles y también
vamos a enfocarnos en algunos ejemplos
usando los elementos más importantes no
veremos todos en este vídeo porque por
ejemplo los metales de transición y los
lantánidos son un poco más complicados
entonces la regla para escribir la
anotación de los gases nobles es muy
fácil simplemente tomamos el gas noble
el gas noble que se encuentra
inmediatamente antes de nuestro átomo o
ion pero que quiero decir con esto bueno
esto significa que nos referimos al gas
noble que se encuentra antes de ese
elemento es decir necesitamos observar
esta columna
esta es la columna de los gases nobles
gases nobles
y vamos a escribir el gas noble entre
corchetes y después el resto de los
electrones aquí escribiremos los otros
electrones usando la misma anotación que
utilizamos para la configuración
electrónica por si no se acuerdan cómo
es no se preocupen veremos algunos
ejemplos para que no haya duda pero
antes de empezar recordemos por qué a
los gases nobles se les llama nobles
bueno eso es porque tienen completo su
octeto por lo tanto no son muy reactivos
porque tienen todos los electrones que
quieren en química veremos que en muchas
reacciones los elementos que no son
gases nobles tratarán de completar su
octeto pero hagamos un ejemplo vamos a
escribir la configuración electrónica
del silicio en la tabla periódica el
silicio se encuentra justo abajo del
carbón y para escribir toda su
configuración electrónica vamos a
empezar por aquí
el hidrógeno entonces el silicio tiene
una configuración electrónica 1 s 2 2 s
recuerden estos son los electrones del
orbital s mientras que estos son los
electrones del orbital p entonces una
vez que llegamos a 2 p 6 vamos a pasar a
3s 2 que serían estos y como aún nos
faltan 2 electrones
escribimos 3 p 2 esta es la
configuración electrónica del silicio
ahora vamos a escribirla usando la
notación de los gases nobles y después
hagamos la comparación vamos a ver el
gas noble que se encuentra
inmediatamente antes del silicio si nos
vamos hacia arriba y hacia la derecha
miren es el neón entonces vamos a
escribir neón entre corchetes
y después escribimos el resto de los
electrones que nos faltan en este caso
para llegar hasta el silicio nos falta
escribir esto entonces 3 ese 2 que
serían estos de aquí y 3 dedos
ahora al comparar las dos formas en las
que escribimos la configuración
electrónica observen que esta parte
corresponde a la configuración
electrónica del neón así que en lugar de
escribir todo esto simplemente
escribimos neón claro suponiendo que
quien vea esto conoce la configuración
electrónica del neón ahora otra cosa de
la que tal vez ya se dieron cuenta es de
que el resto de los electrones los
escribimos afuera de los corchetes y
miren estos son los electrones de
valencia estos son nuestros electrones
de valencia
así que al escribir la configuración
electrónica usando la anotación de los
gases nobles es muy fácil identificar
los electrones de valencia y podemos
saber en dónde se encuentra eso es muy
útil veamos otro ejemplo ahora vamos con
el calcio el calcio se encuentra justo
aquí pero esta vez no vamos a escribir
toda la configuración electrónica mejor
de una vez vamos a escribirla con la
anotación de los gases nobles entonces
vamos a ver el gas noble que se
encuentra inmediatamente antes del
calcio si nos movemos una fila arriba y
todo hacia la derecha podemos ver que es
el argón entonces escribimos argón entre
corchetes
y después que electrones nos faltan que
no forman parte de la configuración del
árbol bueno sólo nos falta escribir los
electrones 4s y tenemos 2
esta es la configuración electrónica del
calcio usando la anotación de los gases
nobles ok ahora
el calcio tendrá su octeto completo
bueno ya sabemos que estos son los
electrones de valencia electrones de
valencia y para que un elemento tenga su
octeto completo necesita tener la
configuración de un gas noble como por
ejemplo la de kriptón o argón en este
caso el calcio prefiere perder dos
electrones que ganar más electrones
prefiere perder dos electrones entonces
cuando el calcio pierde dos electrones
se convierte en el cat ión calcio dos
más y podemos escribir su configuración
electrónica súper fácil porque es muy
corta al perder estos dos electrones de
valencia la configuración electrónica es
la misma configuración electrónica del
argón así que a simple vista podemos ver
que el calcio dos más
si tiene un octeto completo
completo entonces una de las ventajas de
usar la anotación de los gases nobles
claro además de que escribimos - es que
podemos ver fácilmente cuáles son los
electrones de valencia y si el átomo o
jon tiene o no su octeto completo